stroke down so many stereotypes
shattered so many barriers he allowed
the outside public to be like yeah these
WWE guys they may be onto something none
of those opportunities happen without
him by doing what he's done with class
and professionalism
has given opportunity to folks like me
where people were like yeah okay well
I'll I'll take a chance on John I don't
think Dwayne understands the impact he's
had on an entire industry of people he
gave me some great advice uh when I got
the audition for a train wreck the
audition process is scary for me like it
is for most people and it is a business
of failure you know you got to be used
to telling you got to be used to getting
told you're not the right fit and uh I
really wanted this one and
dead man Dwayne which was like just be
yourself man they called you in for a
reason
you we are
and and I was